hi I'm Ryan and I'm going to be watching
the trailer for a million ways to die in
the West now in case you guys don't know
I'm a huge Family Guy fan a huge
American Dad fan and a mediocre fan of
The Cleveland Show which I heard was
cancelled kind of deserved it
Ted hilarious that is [ __ ] funny
[ __ ] homo [ __ ] I'm quoting the
departed that's not Ted I'm quoting you
know I've been following the news feeds
on this stuff and I've been really
waiting to watch the trailers but you're
gonna get two trailers today - you're
gonna get I'm trying to keep my voice
low because I notice it blows out some
people's ear phones but I talk too loud
sorry man it's a trailer reaction I
can't help the way I feel anyway you're
going to get the Super Bowl trailer and
then the red band trailer because I
think the Super Bowl trailer would be a
good tease for the red band trailer I
like teasing myself for another trailer
and then that trailer teases me for the
third trailer and then movie clips that
come next and before you know you've
seen the whole thing before the movie
comes out right Super Bowl oh yeah drunk
before kickoff no reckon you know I
tried to get a commercial for my new
movie on during the game but apparently
it's not family-friendly what I know you
create a Family Guy
that's what I told him but who's in it
it's got Charlize Theron oh yeah Liam
Neeson well here he's got a huge yeah
yeah we've all heard that
oh man take pride in that you want to
see the trailer do it pal alright go
check out the trailer for my buddy sets
new movie at a million ways calm are you
talking to I don't know alright it was a
good teaser for the actual trailer this
is red bad so children cover your ears
because it's uncensored this is no holds
bar or barrel I forgot how the phrase
goes
okay look it's the ice
I said so big so doesn't melt it's
actually really interesting how they do
it is this one company out in Boston
that the American West is a terrible
everything out here that's not you wants
to kill you
angry drunk people hungry animals
outlaws oh the [ __ ] doctor I couldn't
save her she had a splinter doc what the
hell were you supposed to do I would
like to welcome a new member to our
community welcome to our awesome town
what's with this bear every year people
die really everybody hold still people
die the fans die at the fair somebody
and this urn is gone today my god
somebody's gonna get [ __ ] please don't
shoot us on sex night you beat this guy
at a gun fight you're gonna be a real
hero he's the most vicious gunfighter in
the territory we're gonna teach you how
to shoot
oh my god I just broke up with her quick
just pretend you're my girlfriend I'm
his girlfriend
a lot of sexual activity all the time
it's I live inside her letter you get an
address at care of her vagina yep
i'ma get ready I'm about to shoot a full
load at your can that was a long day
this one man wanted me to smoke a cigar
and then like hash on his balls while
I'm jerking him off and it was just like
what can I do this but I did see a job
is so interesting cuz no two days are
alike ja ja ja e Mecca haha Tina I stare
mila kunis in the corner doors the glass
shatters oh stay as chair go booty
what do you say steel bottle of whiskey
we hit the rough lokay idea your dicks
out Oh a million ways to dad the wish
Alex the frontiers no so bad after all
hey it's a sweet young couple can I
interest you folks in a miracle cure
holy [ __ ]
okay I know the Internet is like a place
for people who hate Seth MacFarlane but
that looks like it could be a comedy
classic I'm mean bold that's just a
trailer and for all I know is probably
just a really well cut trailer might not
actually be that funny
it looks hilarious I like how it feels
different from Ted because he doesn't
want to repeat himself it's very kind of
him he's pretty good-looking guy too and
do things with a lot of things what
stuff
American Dad